bc v n assure pas l'unanimité aldo moro
l'italie là c'est de la peur la peur des
casinos les roulettes niçoise conway
sington le printemps des critiques
bonsoir et puis la mort d'un grand
patron
le professeur robert debré en effet
vient de s'éteindre à l'âge de 96 ans il
avait été hospitalisé dans le courant de
la semaine à la suite d'une chute
survenue dans son appartement parisien
médecin bactériologiste pédiatre le père
de michel debré était également un
écrivain de talent c'était un grand
savant au service de l'homme l'a dit
madame simone veil le ministre de la
santé en apprenant sa disparition en
fait jusqu'à la fin de ses jours le
professeur debré a étonné ceux qui
l'entouraient par sa vitalité et les
activités qu'il continuait à avoir
presque tous les médecins de france ont
suivi ses cours en 58 il a fait la
réforme des études médicales qui est
toujours en vigueur
partisan d'une politique de la famille
ou comme son fils michel
ils pensaient nécessaire d'avoir trois
ou quatre enfants robert debré en sommes
très ouverts avait aussi conscience des
problèmes que cela pouvait poser
il y à un peu plus d'un an il nous
parlait de la retraite et du
vieillissement
le vieillissement est très variable dans
sa rapidité suivant les hommes
certains ont peut lire vieillissent
jeunes si j'ose dire
l'autre ont une verte vieillesse et ses
différents sont très marqués est assez
imprévisible
si bien que ce phénomène d'ottawa
l'action sur d'âge la retraite et qu'il
ya quelque chose de brutal imposé la
retraite à tous au même âge
alors qu'en vérité si l'on est maso
calendrier ils n'ont pas le même âge
réel un peuple vieux n'est pas un peuple
qui y traînent longue très longue et
souvent très belle histoire un peu plus
vieux et au peuple ou le nombre les
vieillards le nom des gens d'âge et par
rapport à celui des gens jeunes est trop
élevé c'est précisément ce qui est en
train d'arriver en france est ya déjà
pas mal de temps et en europe et non
seulement l'euro maintenant tout notre
monde occidental ou par suite de la
diminution du nombre des naissances et
d'autre part la possibilité de vieillir
plus longtemps et peuple vieillissent et
je crois que c'est une explication
peut-être la principale
de la diminution de leur pouvoir sur la
terre et en même temps de la diminution
de leur vitalité que je vous chez 4,94
je marche sur 95 mais le professeur
robert debré avant tout a été à pédiatre
un grand p dia probablement le plus
grand pédiatres du monde de notre temps
quand robert debré entre missiles au
début de ce siècle et qu'il décide de se
consacrer à la pédiatrie la situation
était dramatique un très grand nombre
d'enfants mouraient surtout de mahdia
fait chieuse très vite il comprend et
forme son idée établi de données qui
toute sa vie vont le conduire un que la
mort d'un enfant est inacceptable
les deux que chaque enfant est un être
particulier individuel différent des
autres qu'il faut considérer comme tel
et si à l'heure actuelle de grands
progrès sont en cours dans cette
direction dans ces bois qui ont été si
incertaine si mal aisé si l'on peut
espérer voir diminuer le nombre des
enfants malformés diminuer le nombre des
maladies dues à des désordres du
chimiste encore à lui qu'on le doit
c'est un des plus grands médecins de
notre temps peut-être le plus grand qui
vient de disparaître
il n'est pas exclu qu'on parle à jour du
siècle de robert debré pour parler des
presque cent ans qui ont duré sa fille
dans la soirée monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing vient d'envoyer un télégramme
au fils du professeur robert debré à
michel debré dix ans par le rayonnement
international de sa pensée et de son
action robert debré restera comme l'un
des très grands noms de la médecine
française du 20e siècle événements
politiques de ce week-end la convention
nationale du parti socialiste qui siège
depuis ce matin un huit clos c'est
monsieur pierre mauroy qui a ouvert les
débats ce matin en dressant d'abord le
bilan des élections législatives le
parti socialiste a progressé dans 78
départements a précisé pierre mauroy en
notant par ailleurs que monsieur
mitterrand était le plus qualifié pour
être le candidat du parti socialiste aux
prochaines élections présidentielles de
1981 pour sa part lionel jospin qui
faisait un rapport sur les relations pc
ps a été très clair c'est le parti
communiste qui est responsable de
l'échec électoral
il l'a répété à noël copains cet après
midi
je crois que nous retournions
compliments exactement dans les mêmes
termes
disons simplement que du côté du parti
socialiste on peut peut-être constaté un
certain nombre d'insuffisances d'erreur
à l'occasion de la discussion
mais que c'est bien effectivement le
parti communiste qui porte devant les
travailleurs et devant l'histoire
la responsabilité historique de l'échec
de la gauche
je pense que il est utile oui que le
parti communiste pour son propre compte
que nous mêmes en tout cas nous fassions
ce bilan et que nous l'écrivions noir
sur blanc les écrits restent
mais de toute façon effectivement c'est
la masse de ceux qui se reconnaissent
dans l'union de la gauche qui
trancheront pour savoir qu'il ya eu tort
aux et union de la gauche quelle
signification cette expression peut
encore avoir aujourd'hui écoutés
face à l'offensive actuelle du
gouvernement barre qui est certainement
une des plus systématique une des plus
audacieuses peut-être que mène la classe
dirigeante
je pense que la nécessité de réunir
l'immense quantité de ceux qui
travaillent subsistent et que les partis
politiques qui représente cette masse de
travailleurs ont vocation donc à
travailler ensemble bien jean françois
kahn pour le comité central du parti
communiste noël copains pour la
convention nationale du parti socialiste
tous deux vous avez particulièrement
analyser ce qui s'est passé dans ces
deux réunions
j'ai l'impression que sous l'unanimité
il y avait autre chose il y avait des
fêlures des fissures pas ça ne se
passait pas très bien alors d'abord chez
les socialistes mais le copain qu'est ce
qui s'est passé exactement bien il est
peut-être encore trop tôt pour le dire
parce que la convention va se prolonger
encore assez tard sans doute dans la
soirée même peut-être dans la nuit mais
il est vrai qu'il y a eu dès aujourd'hui
une quasi unanimité dans un vote
approuvant ce cas effet la direction du
parti au cours des derniers mois disons
que c'est un vote traditionnel et un peu
formel et il ya contestation
effectivement contestation sur le
fonctionnement démocratique du parti un
peu comme au parti communiste et là
monsieur mitterrand à répondre a répondu
avec vivacité aujourd'hui il a dit en
particulier je rejette l'accusation
d'impérialisme et de présidentialisme
mais je crois que il ne faudrait pas
pousser trop loin la comparaison avec le
parti communiste parce que au sein du
parti socialiste
il y a des tendances qui sont ou des
courants de pensée comme on dit
qui sont parfaitement connus à
l'extérieur s'il ya malaise au sein du
parti socialiste c'est bien sûr parce
qu'il ya une défaite électorale et qu'à
la suite de cette défaite il faut
repenser une action une stratégie mais
disons le clairement il ya malaise parce
qu'il ya aussi un problème de personne
le problème de personne c'est que après
cette défaite électorale un certain
nombre de socialistes
on pensait que peut-être de suivi terran
ne serait plus candidat aux élections
présidentielles de 1981 et quelques
personnalités procès d'intention ou
intentions réelles ont été accusés de se
porter un peu trop vite sur la ligne de
départ pour assurer éventuellement la
succession alors là aussi monsieur
mitterrand réagi avec vigueur
il laisse entendre que la succession il
dit clairement que la succession n'est
pas ouverte
non pas parce qu'il serait lui-même
candidat dès maintenant mais parce que
estime-t-il le parti socialiste a mieux
à faire
au cours des mois et des années qui
viennent et que de s'entre déchirer sur
des questions de cette musique là donc
pour les socialistes noël copains on
passe maintenant aux problèmes
communiste avec la fin donc du comité
central hier soir jean françois kahn est
là aussi
unanimité mais si oui je vais simplement
vous faire état d' informations que j'ai
pu recueillir et qui me semble sûre je
crois que on peut faire confiance à ses
informateurs alors d'abord c'est un fait
que l'argument selon lequel dans les
périodes difficiles comme ça où le pc
contesté il faut resserrer les rangs et
et donner l'impression qu'on est unis à
l'extérieur est un argument qui passe
bien encore dans le parti communiste
d'autant plus qu'on a dit à certains
disons un peu contestataire semblons
unis maintenant et dans quelques mois
quand tout ça sera assez bien on est dur
à dire à certains problèmes
deuxième aspect c'est vrai qu' aucune
aucun des participants à ce comité
central n'a mis en doute le fait que le
parti socialiste était responsable de
l'échec de la gauche et qu'il avait viré
à droite bien et puis il ya eu beaucoup
de gens conjonction intervenu pour
donner raison à la ligne du parti il ya
eu même des interventions très dures
comme celles de monsieur chambaz qui est
un des intellectuels du bureau politique
mais il y a eu des voix discordantes il
ya eu un certain nombre de gens qui se
sont sur tel ou tel point démarquer du
rapport présenté par monsieur marchait
il ya eu ça c'est nouveau il ya eu des
représentants de fédérations par exemple
des récentes paris ou fédération du var
il y a eu députés comme monsieur jusqu'à
il ya eu
intellectuels comme si henri malberg il
y a eu un responsable de la presse
communiste de démocrates manière du
parti communiste comme monsieur minc air
etc
et ça c'est nouveau d'ailleurs un
élément très intéressant c'est que
d'habitude dans le comité central les
interventions sont préparés les gens se
succèdent à la tribune
oui ça ils préparent dans intervention
là une des raisons pour laquelle ça a
duré une journée de plus c'est que
beaucoup de participants ont pris la
parole spontanément de leur banc pour
dire on n'est pas d'accord avec ceux là
où je voudrais discuter tel point et ont
improvisé des interventions et c'est
pour ça que ça a été ça a été beaucoup
plus long bien merci jean françois
raymond barre a inauguré ce matin la
foire de paris c'est le 67e anniversaire
de cette foire qui attend près d'un
million de visiteurs pendant
l'inauguration le premier ministre a
déclaré les français font preuve
d'imagination d'invention et
d'innovation mais la france ne
maintiendra son niveau de vie qu'avec
des efforts et de la discipline est fort
et discipline sont deux vertus que l'on
prête souvent à nos voisins allemands
pour expliquer entre autres leur
réussite économique actuelle de qualité
où kelly faute ajouté tout de même
l'aide du grand allié américain ans
précisément il y a de l'orage dans l'air
en ce moment entre bonnes et washington
un langage peu diplomatique mais qui est
bien proche portant de la réalité si
l'on en croit la vraie colère du
chancelier allemand schmidt hier qui a
parlé d' irresponsabilité pour la
politique économique actuelle de
l'administration carter critiques
sévères et qui ne touche pas seulement
les cônes entre les états unis et
l'allemagne
c'est un peu le monde à l'envers les
belles américaines ne sont plus
inaccessibles pour les allemands une
luxueuse limousine made in usa n'est pas
plus chère qu'une voiture allemande de
classe moyenne ce petit miracle les
allemands le doivent à un deutsch mark
surpuissant par rapport à un dollar
bien mal en point dans le même temps les
soldats américains postés en allemagne
voient leur pouvoir d'achat fondre un
peu plus chaque jour
ils ne sont plus comme il y a quinze ou
vingt ans des consommateurs privilégiées
résultat ils sortent de moins en moins
de leurs ghettos militaire les soldats
us stationnées en allemagne ne sont
vraiment plus les américains blancs
à la source de leurs désagréments une
monnaie américaine dont les parités ne
cesse de chuter ce qui est très mal vu
par les exportateurs qui ont de plus en
plus de mal à concurrencer les produits
américains
les grandes sociétés allemand de riposte
cependant en installant leurs usines aux
etats-unis une bonne opération
comparable à celle que faisait jadis les
américains aux beaux jours du dollar
lors ce qu'ils achetaient des usines en
europe quoi qu'il en soit la politique
économique et monétaire est devenue une
pomme de discorde entre bonnes et
washington autre source de conflits
économiques elle aussi la ferme
intention de helmut schmidt d'équipé le
brésil du général gaye zèle et pour
quelques 12 milliards de deutschemarks
en réacteurs nucléaires et en usine de
retraitement de matières fissiles
c'est encore là une initiative
insupportable pour le président carter
obsédé par les risques de prolifération
de l'armé nucléaire
accessoirement et à travers ce marché
l'allemagne marque en quelque sorte sur
les plates-bandes commercial des
etats-unis et c'est tout aussi graves
même sur le plan militaire allemand et
américain au des motifs d'acrimonie les
élèves modèles de la classe atlantique
de bonnes n'accepte plus d'être placés
devant des décisions prises en solitaire
par le grand frère américain
ce fut notamment le cas récemment
lorsque le président carter surpris ses
partenaires en décidant de ne pas
construire la bombe à neutrons les
rapports entre allemands et américains
sont vraiment des nouveautés ne pense
pas assez souvent à eux à leur situation
à leurs problèmes
donc certaines différences entre les
deux parties mais en même temps peut
constater chez beaucoup de jeunes
allemands un désir de davantage d'égards
davantage de compréhension de la du côté
des américains et dans ce sens ces
jeunes allemands veulent être des
grandes personnes veulent manger à la
table des grandes personnes et ne pas se
sentir dans une situation de tutelle
je crois que c'est là la preuve
qui parle evènement dans ce domaine
est-ce que l'on peut parler dans
l'attitude allemande actuelle d'une
espèce donné au gaullisme
je ne pense pas franchement la situation
géopolitique de l'allemagne est clair il
n'y a pas de l'allemagne entre
l'allemagne et la tchécoslovaquie
les russes sont de l'autre côté il ya
une différence
également dans la mentalité des
allemands par rapport aux français les
allemands de l'ouest sont foncièrement
anti communiste il n'y a pas autant de
nuances dans cette attitude que en
france
le gaullisme ou un nez au gaullisme en
allemand est une intéressante idée mais
je ne crois pas et en donner les
réalités de la situation militaire et
politique que elle pourrait avancer la
sphère du boeing sud coréen avant
dernier épisode ou presque le pilote et
le navigateur du boeing ont avoué leur
culpabilité disent maintenant les
soviétiques il avait compris les ordres
des chasseurs mais ils n'ont pas voulu
se soumettre
ils se sont repentis cela nous suffit
ils sont donc libres ils vont être
expulsés dans la soirée en italie malgré
une nouvelle lettre manuscrite d'aldo
moro et malgré un mystérieux télex
anonyme impliquant les palestiniens dans
l'enlèvement du président de la
démocratie chrétienne il semble bien que
la vie quotidienne reprennent le dessus
la guerre psychologique déclenchée par
les terroristes des brigades rouges
n'empêchant pas une certaine lassitude
des italiens les italiens sont de plus
en plus incrédule devant la tournure que
par la ferme oro est il possible par
exemple call domoraud joue à ce point le
jeu des terroristes
même s'il se trouve prisonnier des
brigades rouges c'est d'autant plus
étonnant que dans sa dernière lettre
parvenue la nuit dernière
un journal de rome aldo moro affirme
qu'il n'a subi aucune contrainte qu'il
n'a pas été drogués
une fois encore puisqu'il s'agit de la
sixième lettre publiée aldo moro
projette sur la démocratie chrétienne
l'entière responsabilité de sa mort
éventuelle
comme si les brigades rouges n'existait
pas comme si cela ne dépendait pas aussi
les terroristes il ya également un côté
irréel
dans cette lettre puisque aldo moro en
tant que président de la démocratie
chrétienne convoque le conseil national
du parti
comme s'il ne s'était rien passé comme
s'il était encore en mesure d'exercer
ses fonctions de président
incrédulité également des italiens
devant la tactique des brigades rouges
comme ans lundi dernier les brigades
rouges demandent à la démocratie
chrétienne une réponse immédiate est
positive à la libération de 13
terroristes et il ne se passe rien alors
est-ce que les brigades rouges sont
réellement intéressés par la libération
de ses traits ce terroriste est-ce qu'il
ne s'agit pas plutôt d'une mise en scène
à épisode destiné avant tout à
ridiculiser à pas fou et la démocratie
chrétienne
alors quand le président du conseil
julian day off titre et affirme qu'il
n'est toujours pas question de traiter
avec les terroristes
on les écoute mais on est un peu
perplexe devant la fermeté d'un
gouvernement qui semble s'exercer dans
le vide
le plus absolu arrêt des travaux pour la
centrale nucléaire de flamanville
le tribunal administratif de caen vient
en effet de décider un sursis à
exécution du permis de construire de
cette centrale plusieurs recours avait
été déposé en particulier par les
agriculteurs
le tribunal a relevé un certain nombre
d'irrégularités à propos de l'obtention
du permis de construire
c'est la première fois qu'un jugement
favorable aux associations d'écologistes
intervient pour arrêter la construction
d'une centrale nucléaire en france
la sphère des casinos aux niçois
maintenant cela se complique
un petit peu plus chaque jour avec par
exemple aujourd'hui samedi la décision
des actionnaires du casino du palais de
la méditerranée d'accepter la démission
du pdg de la société monsieur jean
bûcher avant cela il y à vendredi une
nouvelle inculpation la 17e avait été
décidé par les enquêteurs à propos des
détournements dans les casinos de nice
une affaire compliquée une enquête
difficile
jean jacques dufour est allé sur place
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passait
autour des tapis verts selon les 300
employés licenciés du palais de la
méditerranée
ce serait à l'évidence à cause du
monopole que voudrait s'assurer monsieur
fratoni pdg du ruhl des casinos club et
du sun beach de menton sur l'ensemble
des jeunes niçois qu'on a fermé les
ports
pauli
ghazi longtemps avant
pense que c'est volontairement que
l'entreprise a été asphyxié pour arriver
au point où on en est aujourd'hui c'est
à dire la fermeture d'établissements
la première mesure a été le 1er juillet
77 monsieur fratoni a fait une note de
service pour suppression de chèques
c'est à dire au crédit aux clients et on
comprend bien que les clients d'un
casino sera une pareille des valises
pleines d'argent pour pouvoir jouer
deuxième mesure s'il a été donnée non
réouverture de la banque à tout va ou le
casino ne peut pas essuyé de pertes et
n'a que du bénéfice à faire
deuxièmement plusieurs mois plus tard à
la suite d'une perte au 30 et 40
ils ont fermé le jeu pendant quatre mois
ce qui a attiré la clientèle vers notre
concurrent direct le casino ruhl madame
leroux 56 ans principal actionnaire de
l'établissement et adversaires de
monsieur fratoni fait chorus avec les
syndicats une dame à qui il est arrivé
pendant la période où elle fut pdg du
palais bien des déboires
une lettre j'ai été matraqués
on ne m'a rien ball et pourtant c'était
facile dans ma voiture et le lendemain
on a mis le feu au palais de la
méditerranée tout près de la salle de
jeu ensuite il ya eu une bagarre à la
boîte de nuit
j'ai été obligé de fermer
il y a eu encore d'autres pressions bien
sûr il y a eu aussi cette balle qu'on
m'a déposé dans mon bureau
peu de temps après ce bien sûr que tout
est fait pour que je vendais je ne veux
pas vendre le palais de la méditerranée
jean dominique fratoni patron du ruhl
nous a reçus mais n'a pas voulu être
filmé 54 ans originaire de corse
il a commencé dans le métier en
exploitant dans les années 50 le modeste
casino de sainte maxime
depuis c'est devenu un homme d'affaires
important à toutes ces accusations il
répond mais madame leroux n'a rien à
vendre à cause de sa désastreuse gestion
la société était déjà en cessation de
paiement à l'arrivée de mes amis déficit
de 30 juin 77,1 milliards 700 millions
de centimes et il reprend c'est pour
cette même raison que je ne suis pour
rien dans l'asphyxient du palais comment
accepter des chèques par exemple quand
il n'ya plus d'espèces dans la caisse à
ces éléments il faut ajouter quand même
des faits des rumeurs une ambiance jean
pire rochdi bimbo 48 ans contrôleur des
services hôteliers du casino ruhl est
abattu dans sa voiture en juillet 77
césar valcin ya un moment au conseil
d'administration du ruhl voit son nom
mêlé à des affaires louches et enfin ses
articles dans la presse italienne selon
lesquelles certains casinos de la côte
d'azur servirait à blanchir l'argent de
la mafia pour moi c'est de
l'affabulation
il est bien certain que blanchir de
l'argent sale de jeu c'est excessivement
difficile est quasiment impossible
de son côté jean dominique fratoni qui
contrôle 4 casinos sur la côte d'azur
ajoutent ces rumeurs sont diffamatoires
mensongères et calomnieuses
pour ceux qui s'interrogent sur la
provenance des fonds dont j'ai eu ma
société je peux vous dire qu'un contrôle
fiscal sévère est en cours et que le
résultat contribuera à mettre un terme à
duffel divagation fin de citation bien
ténébreuse affaire un épais dossier qui
s'est encore compliquée quand il y a
quelques jours à l'appel de jean
dominique fratoni qui avait constaté
dans les comptes de son casino un manque
à gagner important
onze policiers parisiens de la brigade
des jeux conduits par le commissaire
divisionnaire saunier arrêté en flagrant
délit un croupier indélicats qui
subtilisé une plaque comme celle ci j'ai
envoyé un fonctionnaire notamment à une
table de blackjack
il a joué quelques temps et ici rendu
compte qu'un d un pompier dérobé une
plaque l'inde refusé dans ses
chaussettes avant de partir à son
vestiaire
à ce jour 17 inculpations ont été
prononcées trésor hull 4 palais de la
méditerranée une affaire déjà peut
plaire à laquelle s'ajoute une autre
interrogation où se trouve la fille de
madame leroux elle même porteuse de
parent est disparue depuis six mois
en attendant pour ne pas perdre leur
emploi 300 personnes continuent
d'occuper le palais de la méditerranée
un puzzle bien compliqué à suivre donc
au chapitre aux sports en cyclisme c'est
le belge et patrick lefebvre qui a gagné
cet après-midi la 4e étape
leon valladolid du tour d'espagne un
autre belge ferdi vandromme conserve le
maillot de leader
et puis on rugby coup d'envoi des
huitièmes de finale dès cet après-midi
sur antenne 2 dans les jeux du stade
vous avez pu suivre en direct lourde
agen ces lourdes qui s'est qualifié pour
les quarts de finale daniel cazals
après vingt minutes d'un jeu assez terne
ses lourdes qui va ouvrir la marque sur
cette action suivez bien le dise
caussade il reçoit le ballon de la forme
saint-eutrope transmet à berbizier
berbizier des joies les joies d'une à
suivre la ligne aride le premier est
aplati un essai qui ne sera pas
transformé 4-0 pour lourdes qui
construit mieux sans que pour autant se
produisent la petite étincelle qui
enflamme le public deuxième mi-temps
lourde à droite mène 7-6 à une pénalité
de berger sco agen ayant répliquaient
par deux pénalités de bernard vivier et
sur cette touche lourdaise
le ballon sort pour lafforgue et
caussade réussit un drop lourds neufs
lourdes mène 10 à 6
26e minute sur une nouvelle touche à
proximité des bus d'agen les avants
lourdais marque un essai en force par
carpentier berger se transforme 16 à 6
carpentier le dernier à se lever à la
dernière minute à jeun réussi un essai
après il touche raccourci mecs te la
donner à cazaubon pour dubroca cazaubon
récupère et envoie belgheri à l'essai
score final 16 dufour l'homme qui
rencontrera le vainqueur de toulon
valence en quarts de finale
événement ce soir sur antenne 2 il ne
s'agit pas du sport et de politique mais
tout simplement de télévision et croyez
moi c'est un vrai événement raison
surtout de la qualité de l'émission que
notre chaîne va vous présenter il s'agit
du premier épisode d'emile zola d'une
série écrite réalisée par armand lanoux
et stellio lorenzi emile zola où la
conscience humaine
c'est évidemment le dossier bien
difficile de l' affaire dreyfus c'est
aussi une remarquable création
dramatique au service de l'histoire
l'ordi
stellio lorenzi est ce que vous avez
fait une oeuvre historique une
dramatique qui fait appel à des bases
réelles ou un reportage sur une
actualité après tout pas si lointaine je
vous répondrai les trois en fait cette
oeuvre historique
indubitablement mais basé sur des faits
réels avec une recherche d'une
authenticité
enfin honnête mais il est évident que
c'est en même temps une oeuvre création
parce que zola c'est pas oh là là qu'ils
convoient sur le film c'est jean tôt par
ce sont des comédiens
donc il ya forcément une distanciation
il ya une création artistique
mais c'est une création artistique
entièrement basées fondée sur des faits
authentiques c'est à dire que deux
oeuvres d'histoire et en même temps
oeuvre de création normative c'est
l'histoire par le truchement de la
dramaturgie télévisuel par cet
acharnement contre un si mauvais coups
par l'antisémitisme seul ne les suit pas
aussi dreyfus a quitté le premier
officier juif
entré à titre permanent aux grands
états-majors vous lisez drummond vous
devez comprendre à l'utilité en effet
sur un dossier secret de tous ses
secrets
un dossier qu'on ne montre pas à
l'accuser pas à l'avocat pas à la
famille
9 ce serait une forfaiture exactement
c'est le mot
on se devait route trois raisons à mon
sens de faire enfin de traiter cette
histoire c'est que d'abord cela est un
homme monumentale sur le plan littéraire
il méconnu c'est un inconnu célèbre
deuxièmement le j'accuse ce qu'il a fait
avec son j'accuse
c'est le watergate à la puissance ans il
ya de ça 80 ans
c'est unique dans notre histoire le
j'accuse et ensuite à lors de l'affairé
dreyfus aussi parce que c'est un
tournant de notre histoire nationale
on peut dire que c'est après l affaire
dreyfus que n'est vraiment en france la
république moderne libéral et
démocratique
voilà juste après zola il y aura le
magazine voir et la dernière édition du
journal présenté par hervé claude vers
23h20 deux mots de la météo avant de se
quitter demain le temps sera couvert et
pluvieux du nord à l'est du pays et sur
les régions méridionales où les pluies
pourront être particulièrement violente
l'après midi sera un peu moins maussade
sur l'ouest où des éclaircies
alterneront avec les averses les vents
de sud seront fort en méditerranée dans
la vallée du rhône
je vous retrouve demain à 13h avec
plaisir et je souhaite une très belle
soirée sur antenne 2